er wird nur noch das monster genannt von
experten der gamma blitz der uns dieses
jahr traf mit der nummer 4 127 kann ein
solcher blitz das leben auf unserem
planeten zerstören
[Musik]
so etwas hatten die astronomen weltweit
noch nicht erlebt der blitz der gamma
ray burst grb 13 04 27
der war so stark dass er die
messbereiche der extra für die messung
solcher blitze gebauter satelliten
übertraf die nasa lud jetzt zur audio
pressekonferenz zum thema der stärkste
blitz aller zeiten an
was da verkündet wurde war eine
sensation ein irrtum ist jetzt
ausgeschlossen die messdaten sind
überprüft es war tatsächlich der hellste
blitz der hellste gamma ray burst aller
zeiten der uns am 27 april 2013
getroffen hat und wir haben glück gehabt
dass wir ihn gefunden haben denn der
satellit fermi der für die messung
solcher blitze da ist er richtete sich
gerade neu aus und fing dann um 21 uhr
47 mitteleuropäischer sommerzeit die
signale aus 36 milliarden lichtjahren
entfernung auf nur eine minute später
waren die automatisierten radioteleskope
auf der nördlichen halbkugel da sind
diese riesigen schüsseln auf die
explosion ausgerichtet und was sie dort
am nördlichen nachthimmel im sternbild
des löwen beobachteten brach alle
rekorde
die messergebnisse sind einfach
unglaublich dieser blitz hatte 94
gigaelektronenvolt dass es außerhalb
jeglichen messbereichs der satelliten
er war 34 milliarden mal stärker als
sichtbares licht und damit dreimal
stärker als der bisher stärkste
gemessene
gamma ray burst zehn sekunden hat dieser
blitz mehr energie ausgesendet als die
sonne in milliarden von jahren
aber was war passiert in einer
entfernung von rund 36 milliarden
lichtjahren war ein stern mit 20 bis 30
sonnenmassen aber nur der drei- bis
vierfachen größe der sonne
zusammengebrochen kollabiert zu einem
schwarzen loch oder einer supernova so
genau weiß man das im moment noch nicht
und in dieser sekunde wurde der blitz
von diesem stern ausgesendet und
normalerweise leuchtet er dann so ein
paar tage ein paar wochen nach aber bei
dem gamma ray burst 427 waren das monat
gut dass das nicht in unserer nähe in
unserer galaxie passiert ist am 27
dezember 2004 aber genau das der fall
der gamma ray burst 04 17 also in märkt
vorne ist immer die jahreszahl und dann
kommt die nummer des gamma ray burst des
jahres das war der 1227 der ist in
unserer galaxie 50 tausend lichtjahre
von der erde entfernt explodiert und die
strahlung war da so stark dass sie auf
der dem blitz abgewandten seite der erde
gemessen werden konnte als reflektion
vom mord wäre der blitz näher gewesen so
rund 500 lichtjahre
dann wären die folgen katastrophal
gewesen der blitz selber der ist
eigentlich relativ harmlos allerdings
basiert er unsere atmosphäre
es entstehen stickoxide und die wiederum
zerstören die ozonschicht und wir wissen
die uv-strahlung der sonne kommt dann
durch und zerstört alles leben
und selbst wenn wir uns dann schützen
könnten vor dieser strahlung alles
andere alles leben was ich ihn nicht
schützen kann
wird von der sonne verbrannt es gibt
keine nahrung mehr genau das könnte aber
vor 443 millionen jahren passiert sein
damals den 50 aller arten auf der erde
ausgestorben und das muster dieses
aussterbens passt exakt zum auftreten
eines gamma ray burst allerdings werden
im moment in der nähe der erde keine
schwarzen löcher oder supernovas
beobachtet die so einen gammablitze
auslösen könnten also die gefahr ist
moment gott sei dank extrem gering
was allerdings diese gamma ray burst und
die schwarzen löcher damit zu tun haben
dass wir vielleicht nur in einer matrix
leben und projektionen sind das erzähle
ich den nächsten mal wenn ihr das ganze
nochmal nachlesen wollt dann gerne auf
dem blog von ging für medien nagelneu
oder stellt fragen was wollt ihr wissen
auf facebook unter anderem oder unter
diesem video
ich freue mich und bis dann bleibt dran
[Musik]